this video is brought to you by surf
shark vpn
hey wisecrack greg here today we're
going to talk about why you don't really
need to be afraid of some
ai fueled robot with aks for arms coming
to snuff you out
now really talk about the terminator
series tends to center around fears of
the coming
robopocalypse you know the day when a
bunch of roided up r2d2s finally come
for us
and it absolutely will not stop
ever until you are dead but what if the
terminator is really warning us
not about some far-fetched apocalypse
but a more subtle danger that's already
here
we'll explain in this wisecrack edition
on the terminator series
and of course spoilers ahead but before
we get into it i want to give a shout
out to this week's sponsor
surfsharkvpn it's no secret that you
don't have much privacy on the internet
these days
however there is a way that you can
protect yourself online
and that is by using a vpn a vpn sends
your information through an encrypted
tunnel
so you can safely use your passwords
without the fear of hackers stealing
your information
a vpn can also protect you from targeted
ads and other pesky data trackers
when you use surfsharkvpn you can use
your account on any of your devices so
you know you're always protected
surfshark isn't just a vpn it also
offers additional features like clean
web
which blocks ads and malware that may
pop up while browsing
their other feature blind search
protects your browser from serving you
targeted ads
or sponsored sites if you use the link
in the description and use the promo
code wisecrack
you can get surfsharkvpn for 83 off that
normal annual price
plus three extra months for free go to
surfshark.dill slash wisecrack
or hit the link in the description
protect yourself online and download
surfsharkvpn today
and now a quick recap when an ai system
designed to run america's defense
network becomes self-aware
it decides the safest course of action
is to nuke the hell out of humanity
and honestly i get it anyway after the
mushroom clouds disperse
a war rages on between man and machine
until the robot army decides to send a
terminator back in time with one mission
kill this perfectly nice lady sarah
connor before she gives birth to the
future leader of the human resistance
but humans from the future send back
their own soldier to protect her
and the race is on who will get the
sarah connor first
and change the course of history come
with me if you want to live
subsequent films in this series have
given us good arnold bad
arnold and stay at home dad arnold his
name is mateo
i met his mother alicia a few months
after he killed john
but each new installment revolves around
the same basic premise
and evil ai tries to kill us all and a
robo soldier goes back in time to try
and save us all
even people who drink hot coffee through
straws
while the sequels have really leaned
into the sci-fi action thing
the original is essentially a horror
film like many classic slashers
it sees a cold-hearted human but not
human entity
stalking relentlessly after what film
scholars call
a final girl aka the female character
faded to survive all the villains bull
unlike
other horror antagonists but exactly
like mark zuckerberg
the terminator puts the cold ruthless
precision of a computer
into a human body it's creepy as all
hell
this basic juxtaposition between
humanity and dead-eyed machine like
logic
is what makes the movie so scary it also
makes you wonder what series really
capable of
i could kill you and they'd never find
the body personally
that's way scarier than me than global
nuclear war
but let's put killer robots aside
because the real strength of the series
commentary
is the way it highlights the subtle
dangers already posed by existing
technology
the original movie was set and released
in 1984
at which point our daily lives had
become increasingly
automated and increasingly relying on
machines and it's this dependence on
technology
that primes many of the terminators
victims for the kill
take sarah's roommate ginger while her
boyfriend is being attacked by a burly
android invader
she remains blissfully unaware thanks to
the headphones
blaring those irresistible 80s tunes
cut to 2020 and we're so dependent on
technology that i for one
have basically hot glued my air pods
into my ear holes
and not to sound like a boomer but i'd
say that spending most of our lives on
screens
often cuts us off from the outside world
and it's not just about how you almost
got hit by a car because you were
sexting either it's also how technology
stops working for us
throughout the first movie the
communication technology that the
characters rely on
constantly fails them phone calls are
missed
voicemails go unchecked and jinger's
boyfriend embarrassed himself by
launching it to a steamy monologue to
his girlfriend's roommate and then
pull your panties off with my teeth who
is this
happens to the best of us i've been
there man believe me
and even after the police know that
sarah is in trouble they still can't get
a hold of her
call her i just call her call her again
and when she tries to call them
the police keep transferring me around
i'm gonna give them another try
here the web of connections that is our
safety net comes
unraveled in a time of real crisis and
that was just in 1984.
these days if the internet went out the
world would probably collapse into chaos
basically when so much of our
communication takes place from a
distance and is mediated by technology
we're left vulnerable in more ways than
one the scene in which ginger has sex
with her boyfriend without removing her
headphones
can even be read as a comic indication
of how technology has come
to interrupt even our most intimate
forms of contact
a study from last year found that 20
percent of airpod users have enjoyed a
similar experience
hopefully while listening to this
american life however the recording that
plays out in response to the police's
unanswered calls
indicates an even deeper problem
hi there i fooled you
you're talking to a machine the t-800
tracks sarah down by impersonating her
mother on the phone
showing how easily good technology can
trick us
i love you too sweetheart today twitter
bots and chat bots alike are both
effective because they give us the
sensation of speaking to a real human
being
of course whether they're being used to
rile us up or calm us down
they elicit an emotional response and
that response can be exploited
and this is a fear that becomes more
potent every year
the t800s vocal mimicry might have been
sci-fi back in 1984 but it's eerily real
in the age of deep fakes
i don't want to have to say because who
knows when you're going to run into
these people
just last year an ai was able to
impersonate joe rogan's voice well
enough to convince listeners
they were speaking with the podcaster
himself at the same time
visual deep fakes are becoming an easy
way to spread very convincing
misinformation
president trump is a total and complete
now you see i would never say these
things
at least not in a public address but
someone else would
someone like jordan peele these days
fears of being lulled into a false sense
of security
by computer tricks is very very real
and samantha i don't care if you're
actually a 71 year old inmate named rod
well we have a special girl and i'll
never regret it
and of course unlike in 1984 computers
are now integral to the fabric of our
daily lives
this reality was explored in a fun if
not completely successful sequel from
last year
terminator dark fate once again the
series tries to warn us about the very
real technological threats we face today
threats mckenzie davis's robot arm can't
possibly protect us from
dark fake puts its hero danny in much
the same position as sarah and john
connor before her
aware that a single-minded killing
machine is on her trail
and desperate to disappear of course
it's basically impossible to get off the
grid when the grid is everything
now anyone with phone is a walking
sensor platform
how every intersection every gas station
and 7-eleven has cameras
nobody walks through this world without
leaving a digital trail a mile wide
throughout the movie the rev9 is able to
track its prey by tapping the huge web
of internet connected devices that now
span the globe
in the original film the t800 happens to
be in sarah's apartment when she leaves
a voicemail revealing her location
i'm at this place on pico boulevard
called technoir
the rev9 doesn't have to rely on such
old tricks
thanks to our smartphones and other
devices we all leave a godzilla sized
digital footprint everywhere
we go while it may save us from getting
stranded like this
it also makes it impossible to hide
whether from facial recognition
technology
or from facebook harvesting our very
personal data
in short a world in which computers
track our every move
isn't the stuff of futuristic sci-fi
it's a world we
and danny are already living in hey
might as well be wearing a tracking
bracelet but it's not all stolen
personal data and targeted
facebook ads the terminator films have
always centered around the most
terrifying technological risk of all
what happens when computers are the ones
with the guns
and before you laugh at the thought of
your room by pulling a gun on you
consider this
the korean border is being patrolled by
robotic centuries equipped with actual
machine guns
now to be clear the manufacturers
maintain that the bots still require
human authorization
to fire so we aren't yet in a world with
fully automated death machines
but they sure seem headed that way as in
dark fate we've witnessed an increasing
use of lethal drones
particularly by the united states which
moves us
further towards a more mechanized vision
of warfare
recently the u.s agency that researches
and develops emerging warfare technology
announced that it has successfully
tested an autonomous drone swarm it's a
far more effective killing machine
oh great that's great so even if we
won't be seeing anything like a t800
stumping down the street
any day soon the military possibilities
of our increasingly advanced computers
should certainly give us pause which
brings us back to the real
problem with our continued panic about
interconnected networks of murder and
leather-clad
killbots not only does it freak us out
but it also distracts
us from the much more concrete dangers
we face today
the world depicted in the terminator
isn't coming anytime
soon but there are plenty of potential
dystopias we can land
in along the way if we're not careful
from the privacy threat
you carry around in your pocket to that
deep fake of you cheating on your spouse
with their dentist
the computers we should be wary of are
already here
but for all the time it's spence
teaching us to be terrified of anything
with wires
the terminator series always ends on a
hopeful note
because technological progress is not
preordained
we get to choose what shape the world of
tomorrow will take
especially if you're elon musk come on
man
don't stop elon at its core the
terminator series is about what
technology can do to us
if we're not careful and about
questioning the role computers should
play in our lives
it's great that we can ask alexa to set
a timer for 420 to
take our vitamins it's less great when
we relinquish
all of our privacy in the process so
what do you think wisecrack
how far is too far when it comes to
computers should we keep pressing
forward
and hope things turn out more next
generation than judgment day
or should we be a little more worried
about the rise of the machines
let us know in the comments big thanks
to our patrons for your support
terminate that subscribe button and as
always
thanks for watching peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you